ينضم الينا هنا في استوديو التغطيه في كيف
انطون جيراشينكو مساعد وزير الداخليه
الاوكرانيه اهلا بك سيد انطون سيد انطون
يبدو الرئيس الاوكراني في مؤتمره الصحفي
واثقا من النصر هل ياتي هذا الكلام
بالاستناد الى بقائع على الارض ام فقط لشد
عصب الاوكرانيين في هذه المناسبه
خاسره
ولكننا لم ننتصر حتى النهايه لدينا الكثير
من الاعمال في المستقبل ويجب ان ننتصر على
اكبر ديكتاتور في العالم كل العالم
المتحضر
اجتمع في حلف ضد بوتين الان
54 دوله تدعمنا بالاسلحه والذخيره وبفرض
العقوبات على روسيا اعتقد ان هذا تقريبا
50% من المعدات في العالم لذلك النصر هو
حليف لنا بكل تاكيد ولكنهم لم يهزموا بعد
ان روسيا تريد ان يقتل الملايين من جنودهم
حتى يسيطروا على
اوكرانيا وعلينا ان نحرر جميع الاراضي
والمواقع بما فيها القرن وكل الاثار التي
حصلت يجب ان نعيد بناءها وقد يصل هذا الى
اكثر من تريليون قريبن وعلى بوتين
وحلفائها ان يدفعوا ثمن كل قتيل وكل
شخص كل منزل دمر وهناك العشرات من الالاف
الذين قتلوا
سيده انطون السيد زيلنسكي اشار الى
الطائرات المقاتله في نفس المؤتمر الصحفي
ماذا عن هذه الطائرات الى اين وصلتم مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بخصوصها
[موسيقى]
نحتاج الى الكثير من الاسلحه حتى ننتصر
على روسيا لقد استخدمت روسيا جميع الاسلحه
بما فيها
الاسلحه القذره واسلحه بعيده المدى
والصواريخ
الباليستيه وصواريخ المجنحه
وشركائنا لم يقدموا لنا الطائرات العسكريه
حتى الان والصواريخ بعيده المدى وهذا ما
ننتظره منهم تعلمون ان قبل سنه كان
الشركاء لا يريدون ان يقدمون لنا الاسلحه
تماما ثم قدموا الهايمرز والان وصلت
اليابات التي قدمها لنا وزير الخارجيه
البولندي ونحن متاكدين ان الاسلحه سوف
تستمر بالوصول من الشركاء نحن لا نحارب
لاجل حريتنا وامننا اوكرانيا تحارب لاجل
مستقبل العالم
حضر والديمقراطيه الليبراليه فرنسا
وبريطانيا لا تهدينا الاسلحه انهم يقومون
بواجباتهم حسب اتفاق
لقد
استغنينا عن الرؤوس النوويه
اذا على اي اساس يقول لوزير الدفاع بانكم
تعدون لهجوم مضاد
على اساس اننا نقوم بجمع جميع الامكانيات
التي سوف تستخدم في هجمات الربيع وليس
هناك اي وسائل اخرى للنصر والانتصار على
بوتين ان اوكرانيا بنسبه 90%
يدعمون الاستمرار بالحرب لتحرير جميع
الاراضي هذه هي الوسيله الوحيده للنصر
وللتامين السلم في اوكرانيا
الاوكراني شكرا لك